the latest effort now to curb raging
inflation rates but it's also causing a
big dip in the stock market leaving many
concerned about what this means for
their 401k and retirement plan sasha
loftis joining us live in our newsroom
tonight with our top story brian and
denise whenever we see news of a big
stock market and economic change we
think about what it means for our future
i spoke with someone who says they've
been planning for the worst but admit
it's impossible to know what will
actually come next
it's scary
sometimes kids have to help their
parents now as the economy continues to
change cindy kester says it's been a
real roller coaster recently we've taken
a major hit and we're in
very safe secure investments she's
considering retirement soon and while
she has quite a bit of money socked away
interest rate hikes and stock market
plunges have her attention inflation is
out of this world right now on wednesday
the federal reserve raised interest
rates by another 0.75 percent in another
effort to curb inflation but this is
also connected to a drop on wall street
with the dow and s p 500 falling by
about 500 points a bit of craziness in
the market unlv economics professor
stephen miller says this has the power
to really affect those ready to cash out
their 401 k
while also facing a higher cost of
living
they're going to be hurt by this
not because of the stock market but
rather because the fed
is going to be controlling inflation
through aggressive policy so if you
still have time to save koster
recommends kicking things into high gear
now
so you're ready for whatever comes next
so you need to plan for yourself and not
rely on others
stephen miller says no matter how close
you are to retirement he recommends
having a myriad of investments with
different risk levels he says while it's
impossible to truly predict he and other
experts hope to see the economic climate
level out by the end of next year